yeah that's a fake sound we've all heard
those trucks and sports cars Roar past
us with deafening engine noises and
whether you're into it or find it super
annoying like I do the truth is this
sound is not necessary it is not like a
byproduct of a really powerful engine
car companies are designing the engines
to be louder on purpose with no power
benefits and sometimes they're literally
Faking It pumping fake engine noises
through speakers why why turns out that
car executives are afraid that customers
will hear quieter engines and think that
their car isn't as powerful they're
literally making them sound worse to
appear better to someone capitalism is
weird y'all I'm telling you this is
weird this is concerning no there is one
case in which making cars artificially
louder may actually have some benefit
and is actually required by federal law
and it has to do with the quietest cars
of all electric cars they're too quiet
these cars are so quiet that you can't
hear them coming and that's actually
potentially dangerous because if you
can't hear a car coming like the car
will hit you I mean yeah okay that makes
sense I guess whatever but do we really
need this